- You're now drumming? (laughs)
You're drumming, I love that
you're family must hate you.
(laughing)
- I mean that's the loudest thing ever.
- Can I tell you? So
my wife calls me Tappy.
- [Kelly] Tappy.
- Hey Tappy, what ya doin' Tappy?
- Oh my gosh.
- So what'll happen is, you'll just
subconsciously be paradiddling like.
(tapping)
- Well especially 'cause if
it's like a new love like-
- Oh my God, it's so much fun.
You know I took it up
when I left the show,
I knew that I would need
something to occupy,
my brain is not a brain
that does well with-
- [Kelly] Sitting.
- Downtime.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- So if I have a lot of downtime it will,
it'll start out with like
you've had a really rewarding career
and end up with you failed
everyone that ever loved you.
(laughing)
- [John] Like it goes there
like almost, you know,
it'll start here and then just like
a day by myself and it just goes
- Yeah
- And I sink.
So I took this up about five years ago
and a buddy of mine was a drummer.
And so he gives me lessons and I at first
I went on YouTube because I really
have always in my life wanting
to interact with music.
Because I feel like it's such
a beautiful language that
I don't speak you know I'm not able to...
- Yeah but you enjoy it
- And so I thought to myself
but I can definitely bang
on (beep) with sticks.
(laughing)
- How hard could that be? Not knowing.
- Wait, that's really hard.
Drumming is hard I've tried.
- I didn't know that. I just
thought it was like (shout)
but it's really nuanced. It's really,
you know what it is, when
you're, so much of it is
limb independence and all of these things.
And it might be a very simple move
but if your body is not
accustomed to that independence,
if you really slow it
down and you work on it
and then it starts to click.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That feeling you could almost feel like
a new syntax forming in your brain
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I swear to you
it's like the opposite of death.
And I swear to you it's
keeping my brain elastic.
- Yeah and you're right. The slowing down
like any form of music
even studies of a kid like,
it's if you slow anything
down it's easier to learn.
It's just having the patience.
Like that's why I couldn't
do piano, like vocals
for some reason when I started
sight reading like with music
I picked it up really quickly,
but piano I just couldn't play Beethoven
like right off the bat, so
I was like fine I'm over it.
- Not doing it.
- Yeah I'm not doing
it. This isn't my forte.
- Yeah, I even like, I
like the busy work of it.
Like he'll send me a
sheet and just be like
just do you know 16th
notes and just bang around.
But you must have known that you were,
you know, I hate to use
the phrase predetermined
but you must have felt an
affinity really early on
because you can't walk
around with a gift like that
and not realize it
probably pretty early on.
- Well, I'm with you then.
So, like I was, I mean, I know
13, isn't old by any means,
but I just mean all, I don't know.
Every time I hear people in interviews,
they're like I've been singing
and dancing since I was two.
(laughing)
And I'm like, not me. Like
I was like, I literally,
You know, everyone sang in my small town.
We all went to church, so everyone sang.
- See I would've thought, for you,
even in a church choir
or something like that,
like even at eight or nine years old,
if you open your mouth,
people are just going to go.
- That, that was odd.
- Not really.
- How'd that happen.
- No. Not really.
- Really?
I had so many
talented singers around me. I really did.
I, I'm, and I, and I know
people always say like,
Oh, oh my god, you sing so well
and you can do so many things.
I was like, I grew up
with a lot of girlfriends
that could do that so it wasn't
really an abnormal thing.
But you keep interviewing
me, John Stewart,
quit interviewing me.
- Sorry.